Hey guys, a couple weeks ago Castrol sent me some of their brand new Castrol EDGE motor oil.
Which is really good timing because I just bought a car that needs an oil change.
Now Castrol claims this is the strongest full synthetic oil money can buy for a whole number of reasons
I'll tell you about later, but before I put this fluid titanium technology in my own vehicle,
I thought it'd be exciting to run a few torture trials of my own.
Now the first experiment in the torture trials is called thermal shock. I brought back the mini metal foundry from a previous project; we're going to use that to
superheat the oil to an extreme temperature and then this little contraption uses a thermos to store liquid nitrogen, and when it's time,
we'll pull the pin from a safe distance;
releasing the liquid nitrogen into the oil, and seeing what kind of reaction takes place when these two extremes collide head-on.
Now of course the disclaimer is don't boil motor oil. This is extremely dangerous
We're in a controlled environment, and this is not something that should be duplicated.
We're just doing it so you can see what happens if you did. Okay, so update,
we've got our thermos locked in the back position,
we've just filled it up with liquid nitrogen to the very top, and if we take the temperature,
you can say it's actually too low to measure.
This is minus 321 degrees Fahrenheit. In contrast, if we look at the oil now, we're about
425 degrees right now. I think it's time to drop the nitrogen.
Alright here we go guys, it's showtime!
Whoah! (Ho! Ho! Ho! Ho!)
That was so much than I expected!
Boom!
(Let’s go check it out)
Oh! Look look look look look [you] still see a little bubbling drops of liquid nitrogen floating on the top there
How crazy is that?
The oil exploded out, and we got a spray radius up to about almost like 20 feet
It was a good idea to be way way back there
[well] a little makeshift contraption worked out pretty well didn't it.
So let's move on to torture trial number two this second torture trial is called terminated
And it'll make sense in just a second. The idea is to use liquid nitrogen to see if we can get motor oil to freeze
Completely solid and help me do that I've got this cake mold that I got off the internet
[this] is designed for baking and is made of silicone and should be able to handle temperatures of about 300 degrees
Which is what our oil is at right now
So let's fill our mold up with oil
Gently add Liquid nitrogen around the edges and see if we can get motor oil to freeze completely solid
Check that out, that's awesome
Oh, that's amazing
It's making little crystals. I'm not sure if it's doing that through the whole thing or if that's just on the surface
It's definitely unique formations. [well], that's enough time for me. Let's take this thing over to [Tray] and smash it
It's pretty solid
Question is can we get them out. It's like the rubber and the oil have become one. I cannot physically separate them right now
I wonder if we [should] just smash it in the tray that might be the best bet.
There we go.
That is insane you're looking at frozen motor oil. That is nuts
Look at that [guys] our motor oil seems to have survived test number two
Which is more than I can say for the silicone mold let's get this over to trial number three the blend test.
Now I just went and bought a high speed blender because for this last torture trial
I want to see how [our] oil holds up to the extreme mechanical turbulence generated by metal moving at high speed
Now this thing's been running for well over [ten] minutes
The only real difference that I've noticed [is] the temperature has risen to over a hundred and fifty degrees Fahrenheit
And that's because of all the heat being generated by the friction of the blades spinning around so fast okay check this out
It's been over 20 minutes now, and I think our blender is breaking down because I can see some oil spilling up the back
Whoa that's hot that's hot. That's hot. Yeah, that's almost 200 degrees. This oil has been through a lot
Which is really amazing because it looks almost exactly like it. Did when it first came out of container. We have boiled it
We have frozen it solid we have smashed it and we have blended it
And it seems to have passed all those tests with flying colors so as a final
testament to my commitment and confidence and casserole Edge motor oil
I'm actually [going] [to] put this stuff in the engine of my car and drive it around the country just to see how it holds
Up after all that abuse now here's the thing about cars if you want them to treat you well you need to pay very
Special attention to what you put in [your] engine and here's why today's engines are smaller and [even] more powerful than they were before which
Means they run hotter and have to handle extreme temperature shifts the metal parts in your engine move at jet speed
Creating insane amounts of pressure and the only thing keeping the whole system from blowing apart is a thin layer of oil that
Lubricates and cools the engine and to help spread the [word] about it. [they] made a really cool video
They want me to tell you about featuring world-class driver's racing digital clones of themselves
With the goal to try and beat their own best tire
It's never too late to get better performance from your car
So consider switching from conventional oil to [Castro's] full synthetic motor oil Castro Edge
oh and feel free [to] replace the oil that's already in there because contrary to popular belief you can switch between
Conventional and synthetic oils as often as you want without harming your engine at all well
Thanks so much for joining me for these extreme experiments today guys and thanks to Castro for supplying the oil
And of course it goes without saying these experiments cannot be duplicated at home
But I was glad [to] have you [along] for the ride, and I hope to see in the next video. [talk] to you then